is it ironic is it bizarre that the
movie The Matrix in 1991 31st of March
tired of using these Haram dating apps
and not getting nowhere with it that's
why we created uni students match first
ever matchmaking service for Muslim
Universal students and graduates sign up
now to find your spouse I'm sure you
guys are now aware all over social media
that Andrew Tate has been released now
I'm not going to be speaking about his
release per se this video is going to be
something where you might be thinking
it's a conspiracy theory but to be
honest we don't believe in coincidences
and we as Muslims believe in the
metaphysical world the metaphysical
reality the metaphysical laws which are
Jin and shayateen we believe they exist
and that's why Allah got Almighty and
his messenger has given us protocols to
take precautions to protect ourselves
from that kind of harm as well as
physical harm or from people that might
want to harm us physically this is a
reality that exists now I don't know if
they're the Illuminati I don't know if
you call them the Matrix I don't know
what you call them but what we know is
that there is an evil presence in this
earth to corrupt us all and for us to
all end up in Hellfire that's what we
believe the job of idlis is now is it
ironic is it bizarre that the movie The
Matrix in 1991 31st of March was when it
was revealed released and very bizarrely
in 2023 on the 31st of March which is
yesterday Andrew Tate happens to be
released from prison are they playing a
game with him are they trying to play
Mind Games what are they trying to do to
me it seems very clear that there is a
force out there that has great great
power more powerful than any president
which are puppets and to me it just
seems like they are saying we are in
control and we will do as we please
that's what it is they have gained so
much power whoever they may be whatever
they are that they can now easily come
out and do these things openly how The
Simpsons know certain things that occurs
in the future how are there certain
movies that are predicting these things
do you think it's all a coincidence not
really I don't believe in conspiracy
theories a lot but some of them speak
damn truths we need to wake up and stop
sleeping the main drop of Satan is to
take all of us down to the pits of the
Hellfire with him and for us the only
way to free our shackles is by
submitting to Islam Islam is the only
Force spiritually physically emotionally
psychologically whatever you want to
name it a fighting force against these
dark Forces and they blame Islam but
deep down why why is Islam a big threat
because Islam is the only way of life
that directly challenges these
individuals by freeing the human being
and the mind and the soul to subservance
subservience to from the human being to
the Creator this is the main one of the
main purposes of Islam to free the
shackles free the Mankind from the
shackles of enslavement to all these
wealthy things to the enslavement of God
Almighty and that is when you will
attain your true Freedom guys I don't
believe it's a coincidence 1991 31st of
March Matrix movies released and then
Andrew Tate about 14 years later comes
out on 31st of March nah I'm sorry this
here raise some eyebrows and get you to
thinking if you really want to fight The
Matrix then you should accept Islam and
I'm not saying that's one of the reasons
Islam is the truth and his evidences are
in the Quran read it for yourself there
is a God damn reason why Andrew Tate
decided to embrace Islam because he
encountered those dark Forces those dark
Forces and the reason I am now so
absolutely certain that God is real is
because I've seen evil I've seen shaytan
and there are people out there in the
world today doing the work of the devil
genuine demons who are trying to destroy
the Baseline morality that's inside of
all of us and God knows where else is
going to end up or are they going to try
to finish him but the fights will
continue join the Believers folks who
are watching this who are Muslim adults
who are not Muslim and understand this
is the war this is the battle that we
must all face to save our soul and our
children soul from the enslavement to
these dark Forces who are playing mind
games and making us fight each other the
only enemy you have is Satan and Satan
is behind these dark force break that
cycle today by reading and that's all I
wanted to say I invite you all to Islam
assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters please watch the
video at the end here and support our
campaign goodbye
54.7 yes that's not how old I am I mean
even looking bold but what that means is
if somebody prays once Allah in the
Haram it's as if they are prayed 100
000 salahs they start praying five times
a day for 54 years we have a brother
here who we are teaching how to pray
Salah and in fact many people learn from
this match and come to the Haram and if
you donated from one mat and somebody
paid two days Salah here it's equivalent
to one million Salas so just a mere 100
pounds can be 10 million asanas and by
the way this is not including their
daily prayers throughout their life and
them teaching their children so if
somebody donated one match and somebody
paid here for two days that's equivalent
to one million the reward is here
inshallah I can't make your hands donate
only you can but if Allah has written it
for you you 100 will click the button or
the link and be a part of this amazing
project
foreign
[Music]